[Música]
durante más de un siglo esta tableta de
chocolate en forma de triángulo ha sido
definida por su tradición Suiza
pero cuando se trata de reivindicar lo
hecho en Suiza parece que no hay
territorio neutral la empresa matriz
estadounidense de toblerone está
trasladando parte de su producción a
Eslovaquia lo que significa que el
chocolate ya no cumple la definición
legal para considerarse suizo la marca
pronto eliminará cualquier referencia
que está hecha en Suiza y perderá la
icónica imagen del pico de la montaña
materhoon sustituyéndola por algo más
genérico la empresa lo anunció
relanzaremos el envase de toblerone a
partir de este verano diciendo que la
marca fue establecida en Suiza en 2017
los legisladores suizos aprobaron una
ley que prohíbe que los símbolos
nacionales aparezcan en productos que no
cumplan Los criterios de suizo la ley
exige que cualquier artículo alimenticio
que se comercialice como hecho en Suiza
obtenga el 80% de sus materias primas
del país esto aumenta al 100% para los
productos lácteos ha habido polémicas
similares en torno al queso suizo el
viernes pasado un tribunal de Estados
Unidos dictaminó que el queso no tenía
que producirse cerca de la frontera
Franco Suiza para llamarse gruyer el más
reciente desarrollo en una larga lucha
legal internacional
en cuanto a tolerone el nuevo envase se
presentará este verano y la empresa
afirma que incluirá un nuevo tipo de
letra y logotipo distintivos y la firma
de su fundador suizo que creó la tableta
de chocolate en 1908